this morning on the dish
our visit to a remote island off the
coast of maine for a clambake
put on by even tide one of the most
successful seafood restaurants in the
country
the team who started even thai just
released their first cookbook called
eventide a tribute to friendship fishing
and classic seafood dishes pushed to the
edge
of perfection
our journey began by boats in casco bay
off the coast of freeport maine our
guides
james beard award winning chef andrew
taylor and his business partner arlen
smith
the destination little whale boat island
welcome good to be here once ashore the
ingredients for our feast were brought
in
and the wood was kindled quinn big is
going to happen yeah baby
waiting in the wings a smorgasbord of
delights from the waters of casco bay
oh there we go yeah you want help with
that yes sir
[Applause]
all of it layered with freshly gathered
seaweed for true ocean flavor
a tradition pioneered by native
americans
as the fire warmed taylor had time to
forage for extras
across this 22-acre island on a
picture-perfect day
a skill he's honed over a lifetime of
living the new england lifestyle
this is what i really was going for for
the uh you know the mignonette this is
called c-rocket
these are c-rocket pods the culinary
experience the eventside founders were
creating for us here is something
they've been trying to do in one way or
another for diners
in maine for the past eight years it's
like a fine dining aesthetic in a
casual place yeah yeah we we wanted to
keep the atmosphere completely casual we
wanted it to feel almost like a bar
really
but at the same time serve really kind
of like elegant and interesting food
portland maine has become a culinary hub
in recent years
and making a mark is not easy even tide
has excelled by putting a unique twist
on the classic sea shack one of the
things you talk about a lot in the book
is the fact that some of these
shacks in other places have been around
for generations and yet you were
surprised at the lack of sort of
creativity
or change that's come about in some of
these dishes
it's not even something i necessarily
think is a negative you know
people people love the standbys i mean
people come to maine for a classic
lobster roll or a boiled lobster and
and there are plenty of places to do
that and we just wanted to do something
a little bit different with those places
as sort of like our baseline
but we came out with more of a culinary
sensibility that includes their
signature
a lobster roll with brown butter served
on a chinese style bun one of the best
lunch plates we've ever had
a wide variety of succulent main oysters
and fresh local tuna sliced thin and
served crudo style
on the day we visited even during a
pandemic there was a
three-hour wait for lunch by
mid-afternoon
why does a place like even ty do you
think just take off from the beginning
i do think that event in particular gave
people something that they wanted when
they came to maine
and you guys had like a 20 or 30 year
plan when you first opened right like
there was an effect there was a detailed
exact outlook on what was yeah
yeah we didn't know what we were doing
and uh it was a it was a total fiasco
to be perfectly honest um we
grossly miscalculated how busy we would
be how much did it did it surprised you
that it was such a hit
i think quite a bit i mean it truly
honestly surprised
us um but but maine can be a struggle
maine can be difficult
oh it smells good back on little whale
boat island
on the morning of the clambake the pot
was getting closer
you'll start to see some steam coming
from the top and once the steam starts
it's usually around
15 minutes 10 15 minutes there is the
intimidation factor about clam bakes
people think they're complicated like
that's
you can make that somebody can make that
you make that right at home right in
your stove at home
or outside in your fire pit or put it on
your grill outside
taylor stacked up a gorgeous display
choose your own adventure here that's
what i love about it
don't mind if i do and
the big boy hello
lobster corn knock wurst eggs
steamers and mussels with steam buns
all served with butter and a nuri
mignonette for dipping
delicious well the mini nuts is
fantastic yeah it's really good right
oh my gosh yes
to finish it off an even tied specialty
the e t and g our house tonic is made
with uh cinchona bark and a bunch of
other herbs and spices this already has
the gin in it
you said in the book there might be
nothing better than this to drink with
oysters
nope why i think partially
for me it just just feels like summer
so we do that and then uh just soda
water and a lime of course
cheers cheers it's a little whale boat
and great food and drink
and friends indeed
it's yummy it was yummy and our sincere
thanks to the maine coast heritage trust
for helping to facilitate that trip
and also helping to protect some of
these islands over the years
which makes this possible and people
able to get there beautiful
food beautiful setting michelle has a
question for you
i'll make a handbag for you i'm happy to
i don't eat clams or lobsters that's
that's the only reason you're up there
well there's other good stuff though
there
yeah the corn the potatoes and the point
is that the
clambake is as he said in the piece it's
not that difficult to make just look
that was good that was great all around